what's the last step of building this
cake christine okay my friend this is
the part that like you have the eye i
know you're gonna thrive in it you
already crushed building the cake it's
decorating the top so we make these
little sandy things that we call
birthday crumbs they're like a
shortbread version of the sponge cake
itself
yeah exactly exactly
and this is where you just let the you
of you come to life there's no right or
wrong way to decorate the top of a
birthday cake but you've got birthday
crumbs you've got birthday sprinkles and
i've got knives and forks at the ready
because the best part of dessert come on
is eating oh yes this is true you worked
hard on this my friend interpretive and
be interpretive go get it
true
get it get it get it
she's got it
this is what it's about
yeah
wrinkles cure everything kind of it like
the sort of like no of course we know
they don't but you want to know what
they do something to us and that is like
the spirit and the energy and the moment
that makes us feel good and whole and
makes us want to give that goodness and
that wholeness and give it to anyone and
everyone and that's that's the spirit of
dessert can save the world i mean i know
it's supposed to go on okay well do you
want me to well i mean
i'm like you don't need a plate i look
at you
but i suppose it's the is that the right
thing to do yeah whatever
it's all going you want to know what
also i love that your decor moment
is about just making a little bit of a
mess which i'm a really big fan of also
i think putting like a nice napkin and a
little plate if you're cooking an egg
and some spinach for yourself on a
saturday morning and you're totally by
yourself
it can make such a difference to your
mood yes but i mean if this doesn't make
your mood happy nothing will by the way
here we go
cheers
this is it right this is it
thank you
thank you christina tosi get your copy
of dessert can save the world because it
can and it's in stores now
thank you christina
let's have another microphone
the magical night i just want to say you
crushed it
you would survive the milk fart kitchen
look at that
come on
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
you